hundreds of clark county homeowners
rushed out to the assessor's office
today hoping to meet a major deadline
some are fearful their property tax will
soar to eight percent christian cousins
joins us live in the studio with more
that's right brian vanessa the clark
county building was packed today with
homeowners scrambling to meet a deadline
they tell us after the county's website
crashed and their phone lines were not
working many decided to go in person in
hopes to avoid a property tax hike
that's a huge hike with everything going
on right now that's a very huge hike i
mean who can afford it i mean it's just
ridiculous don't panic they're going to
have you fill out a form
shortly hundreds of homeowners rushed to
the assessor's office on wednesday
fearful of a deadline they believed
would push property taxes through the
roof my co-worker sent me a link and
said my home was at eight percent go
check i checked online and it said eight
for money many like the williams
claiming the county's website and phone
lines were not working we tried to do
that this morning it didn't work so we
just came up here and then we see all
the other people that it must have
didn't work for them either clark county
assessor brianna johnson apologizing to
all residents over this video call and
claims the rush was not necessary she
says only homeowners who recently
purchased a home or had a change in
their title need to come forward check
which box signing dated
johnson stated it's the homeowner's
responsibility to inform her office if
their home is their primary residence
which would cap their taxes at 3 percent
otherwise 8 percent would be the default
for properties like commercial or open
land regardless adjustments throughout
the fiscal year can be made she says
until june of 2023 for this couple they
blame the lack of organization from the
county for the mess we were blessed we
took care of it
and we're good
thank you so much
well clark county assessor brianna
johnson stressed that adjustments on
property taxes can always be made
throughout the fiscal year so there
really is no need to worry so head over
to eightnewsnow.com right now there you
can find a link to take necessary action
if needed christian casa is live local
now christian